we think you're such a great spider-man
Tom Holland you really are the perfect
Peter Parker and we think you're just so
relatable for a superhero we love what
the MCU did with your spider suit Tony
Stark really came through for you it's
evolved throughout the movies and it's
just so cool it's too bad you kind of
hate it and realize though the real
thing is definitely not as practical as
spider-man wants us to believe movie
costumes are an important part of what
makes characters so iconic but the
actors who play them don't always like
what they have to wear let's check out
ten actors and actresses who hated their
costumes Jennifer Lawrence has mystique
you probably know Jennifer Lawrence best
as Katniss Everdeen from The Hunger
Games trilogy but Jennifer also starred
in four x-men movies between 2011 and
2015 the mutant shapeshifter
when mystique is in her natural form
she's bright blue with unique features
but getting into this costume was
unpleasant it took six hours every day
to cover her in blue body paint and
prosthetics and the costume she wore was
very restrictive she has said it was
super hard to answer nature's call
between tapes she couldn't sit down and
had to use a funnel and since that
wasn't the most natural way to do things
she said that the suit eventually got a
slight smell cu was poor Jennifer she
wasn't the only mystique to hate the
costume in earlier x-men films Rebecca
rahmatan had no costume over her blue
paint
she felt super exposed and the process
to apply it took eight hours and for
makeup artists mystique is such a cool
character to play but we aren't sure
we'd want to undergo all that trouble
either would you Scarlett Johansson as
Black Widow women in superhero movies
often have to wear very tight and
restrictive costumes but Scarlett
Johansson might have the worst story
about her costume ever
scarlet plays Black Widow in the
Avengers movies and several other MCU
films you might think it looks like a
pretty simple costume but that is not
the case this black jumpsuit is super
restrictive and very hot no not that
kind of hot
we dean that scarlet had to wring out
the sweat from her socks every day she
would get really overheated in her
costume one time she got so hot during
the filming of a fight scene that she
ended up hallucinating
who knew a costume could be so dangerous
she also hated how tight the suit was
Thor was able to have a small fan
installed in his costume but her
costumes were too tight for that she
couldn't wear anything underneath it
whatsoever the conditions of the
jumpsuit caused it to weather easily so
Scarlett went through several of them
during the filming process Ralph Fiennes
as Voldemort Harry Potter fans know that
he-who-must-not-be-named is one of the
creepiest villains of all time this
wizard did so much dark magic that he
basically looked like a snake human
hybrid it wasn't easy to pull off this
look in the movies Ralph's played the
Dark Lord and he has complained about
the makeup process he had to be
completely painted with white makeup to
give him that signature creepy gray look
he had to wear prosthetics to cover up
his eyebrows and give his face the right
shape he also had to wear fake teeth
they got rid of his nose with CGI which
was good for the actor but Ralph got
really tired of the long process wearing
that much makeup and prosthetics can get
really tiring maybe some of his
Voldemort anger came from that Ralph is
a great actor and no one could have
played Voldemort better than him but he
has said that he has considered turning
down future roles if they require a
similar costume that's how bad he hated
it Anne Hathaway as Catwoman everyone
knows Batman's famous frenemy Catwoman
Catwoman was added to the comics to
spice things up
she's been portrayed in films many times
Catwoman is easily recognizable in her
black leather bodysuit and cat mask some
actresses have found the suit really
empowering like Halle Berry but Anne
Hathaway disagreed she hated her costume
with a passion in fact she has called
the suit psychological torture she
became obsessed with how she looked in
it the tight suit really did a number on
her body image she said that even when
she wasn't wearing it she became
obsessed with fitting into it and
looking good
she was so infatuated with working out
to the point that it was unhealthy we
can't imagine having to wear something
that really messes with our self-image
that has to be hard another
catwoman agreed Michelle Pfeiffer who
played Catwoman in the 90s said it was
probably unhealthy she tried to squeeze
into the suit until it hurt
Tom Holland does spider-man Tom Holland
is the latest spider-man a young actor
has stolen fans hearts as the marble
hero spider-man soo is really important
to the story in fact he even tries to
tell Tony Stark in the first movie that
he's nothing without it but the real
suit that he has to wear is not at all
enjoyable first of all the suit is so
tight that he can only wear special
undergarments that aren't exactly
comfortable he also has to remove the
entire thing to answer nature's call
which is no easy task
one version of the suit was just one
piece so the mask was attached this made
it really hard for Tom to stay hydrated
on set the crew had to stick a straw
through the eye socket for him to take
sips of water he also wears a helmet
under the mask
and it can mess with his vision not only
is that uncomfortable but it's also
dangerous his vision was so impeded that
he didn't see a stunt double that was
supposed to fake punch him poor Tom
ended up getting punched in the face for
real as a result are you a total movie
buff you'll fit right in up the things
click that big red subscribe button and
turn on notifications to never miss
another video be sure to check your
notification settings if you're watching
on your phone Anthony Daniels as c-3po
you might not recognize this actor by
name but we bet you recognize his
character the latest Star Wars movie
comes out in December of 2019 and all
generations of fans are excited c-3po is
the super smart droid from the Star Wars
franchise Anthony Daniels has been
playing c-3po since the very first movie
over 40 years ago he has been in almost
every episode of the saga he takes pride
in being the only person who is willing
to wear the suit but he's pretty honest
with how miserable it is to wear it back
in the 1970s the suit injured him almost
as soon as he put it on the first time
the second step he took caused one of
the legs to shattered this drove a sharp
piece of plastic into his foot it was a
big injury that caused him a lot of pain
he also said it's really hot to wear a
lot of the movies have been filmed in
the desert
so that makes it even worse you know
which Hogwarts student in Harry Potter
hated their costume the most keep
watching to find out margot robbie as
Harley Quinn some costumes may not be
physically uncomfortable but they can
really make an actor feel self-conscious
margot robbie plays the criminally
insane partner to the Joker Harley Quinn
Harley is known for wearing sparkly hot
pants and pink and blue pigtails Margot
says the character likes the costume not
because of the suggestive nature but
because it's fun but Margot as the
actress can't stand her costume it was
very revealing and it made her feel very
self-conscious she said she was hyper
aware of her appearance she'd go to eat
hamburgers on her lunch break and worry
about the way she looked in one scene
that was filmed right after lunch she
had to be hosed down it made her white
t-shirt extra clingy and she was not
comfortable at all
Margot wasn't really a fan of the way
her character was portrayed as a flirty
suggestive symbol in the costume
chadwick boseman as Black Panther fans
fell in love with the world of Wakanda
and black panther chadwick boseman is
the perfect actor to play the king and
super hero in the movie two challahs
smart sister designs his black panther
suit is it we're up to Cherie the suit
would be really easy to move and breathe
in but we don't really have wakanda's
technology so Chadwicks costume was not
nearly as cool the costume was so tight
that Chadwick had trouble breathing in
it that's not a good thing considering
all the fight scenes he had to film it
was so tight that it was hard to put on
and even more challenging to move around
in it was also really hot they were
usually filming in 90-degree weather
which made chadwick hate it even more he
sweat a lot and couldn't scratch any
itches chadwick has said that he had to
get into a mental Zen space in order to
get through the scenes Jim Carrey as the
Grinch everyone loves the holiday
classic How the Grinch Stole Christmas
Jim Carrey is just so believable as the
green Christmas hating guy who lives
north of who-ville it might be because
getting into costume was a miserable
process so Jim didn't have to act all
that upset when filming first started it
took eight hours to transform into the
Koran
that's a whole workday and he still had
to film Jim has described the process of
getting the makeup prosthetics and fur
as being buried alive they even had to
bring in a CIA operative who trained Jim
on how to withstand the process that's
super dark for a family holiday movie
eventually they figured out how to get
the process down to a little over two
hours but Jim had to be transformed into
the Grinch over 90 times for filming he
hated it every time we're definitely
going to watch that movie with a new
appreciation Matthew Lewis as Neville
Longbottom Harry Potter fans love
Neville Longbottom he was the shy
awkward kid who ended up leading the
resistance at Hogwarts and slaying the
guinea people have talked for years
about matthew lewis's glow-up after the
movies he no longer looks like the young
Gryffindor we grew up watching on the
big screen but here's the thing he never
really looked like that Matthew had to
wear a fat suit to play Neville for most
of the movies puberty is hard enough but
it was extra hard for him because
everyone thought he was larger than he
actually was even the girls on set
didn't realize it was just a suit it
really did a number on his self-esteem
he also had to wear false teeth that
were yellowish the makeup department put
prosthetics behind his ears to make them
stick out it's hard enough growing up in
Hollywood but having to look extra
awkward is tough knowing this we're not
too surprised that Matthew hated his
Neville costume and that's it for the
ten actors who hated their costumes
which costume from this video do you
think sounds the worst to wear let us
know in the comments section below
thanks for watching don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up see you next
time
you